man when you look at the discography of
records that I have man you'd be
surprised sometimes I can forget how
many hit records I got
[Music]
it
down to the town
[Music]
at this time I was still a radio
personality in Atlanta Georgia on a
station called hot 97.5 which is now Hot
107.9 not much money in my pocket you
know what I mean still pretty much just
making it day by day but it engulfed in
music and loving every aspect of it and
just waiting for my opportunity to shine
and this was my opportunity
verse kick the tree and if you like it
in the club we can do it in a DJ booth
we're in the back of the VIP fantasy was
produced by Bangladesh who was my barber
at the time and we had a flip side
because it was vinyl at the time on the
other side organized noise produced a
song called game got switched and I was
just going back and forth about which
song I should release first because on
one hand you had to organize noise they
were already established they had
produced records with outcasts and
Goodie Mob and all these people and see
seem like the obvious choice but then I
had fantasy and I was like but this
doesn't sound like anything out this is
uniquely ludicrous I prayed on it man
and I literally just one day said I'm
going with fantasy and the rest is
history Cadillac grills
grills check out the oil Mike
the last inning of the game you know
what I mean trying to get everything
together we had a deadline went to
Pharrell and we did this record man at
first I thought it was just okay you
know I'm in the car writing to this
record literally we went to Virginia
Beach this is where Pharrell was at he
played the beat I liked it went into the
parking lot in the car that's where I
write my music in the cars where I write
my best music and was writing to it came
back in maybe about 45 minutes an hour
later started spitting the verse we came
up with the hook together and I just
remember arguing like man I like this
record but I don't know man I don't know
if it's a smash I don't know if it's a
smash and I love saying this because it
doesn't happen often I was wrong that
record's a smash hit by stars
hit by cars drunk off the liquor getting
hit by bars keep your girl close cause
she's hit by a ball hit by the Neptunes
hit by guitar be hanging upside down
that video something that you know a lot
of people may not know I just eaten
maybe about 45 minutes before shooting
that scene where I'm hanging upside down
definitely threw up like a
and as soon as I did it I was like all
right let's keep going I'm ready ready
to roll
[Music]
I've got home
so area codes came about in such an
organic way this is my first time
traveling the world going from City to
city and definitely picking up numbers
and hollering at women in every single
City so I had this mental Rolodex no
matter where I was at I know if I was in
Jersey I was like 201 if I'm in New York
718 you know I would have all these
different numbers and we were sitting in
a limo one day the whole crew and
somebody was like oh it was 305 and we
was like that's Miami that's one of your
hoes in Miami you know somebody else was
ringing it'd be like oh it's 813 oh man
that's Tampa man you got to know that so
it was almost like this extreme game
that we would play because we would
never record their names into it we just
got the phone number so you'd have to
remember what city every area code came
to so that record is 100 organic in
terms of working with Nate Dogg I
believe I sent him the record we had
worked with him in studio so many times
but this particular time I believe we
sent it to him and waited for it to come
back when we got the record back we knew
it was instant classic that one I knew
[Music]
I just vaguely remember like when he was
single we need a single you know that
whole game you play with the with your
record label and the commercialization
of trying to continue stay authentically
yourself as an artist ludicrous but also
understanding the politics of the game
and knowing that you want something to
hit number one we went to Timberland he
made it happen man and even more so when
we were shooting this video the video
for roll out before the Big Head Post
effect was there we didn't feel like we
had a good enough video like it was just
regular everybody was like this isn't
good enough Def Jam was like it's good
enough it's cool but it's not what we
need and then I don't know if I came up
with the idea it probably was because of
my craziness I was like let's put a big
ass head on me and just make it Bobble
and that was that one factor that made
that video turn from just okay to out of
this world to Ludacris so that's
the rollout aspect of it but we got our
hit from Timberland thank you number one
record and we also got a video that just
moved people's image designation to a
whole other place
[Music]
no joke I I told you some of my best
music is written in the car I'm driving
on the highway one day just frustrated
and again authentically organically
somebody's in front of me and while I'm
writing to this track it just occurred
to me just move get out the way
and it's stuck and in the video of
course the stars all align exactly the
way that they needed to the afro being
out all the guest appearances on there
my own homie Infamous 2-0 you know being
from Decatur it was just one of those
records that just moved the needle until
this day people ask me what's my
favorite record and I have to you know
be political and say what do you mean if
you're talking about performance
strictly performance that record is
unfair because people pay to come see me
in concert and when we do Move
they're the ones that singing the record
and I'm just have the microphone held
out so they're paying to hear themselves
sing and perform it's unfair oh you just
came home from doing a bid tell me what
you gonna do
I was on tour with Eminem at the time
and I got a call from John Singleton he
had hit my agent and then they put me on
the phone with him and he said he wanted
me to try out for Too Fast Too Furious
like he's sending me the the dialogue
and the sides that I have to perform in
front of and he's like I really need
this within this certain amount of time
so it was a rush I'm about to go on
stage you know on the Eminem tour in
like 40 minutes so I'm going through
these lines we go get a camera I'm kind
of studying the stuff put myself on
camera and do the lines next day I get
the call that I got the part that all
happened within 24 hours the craziest
that ever happened in my life later
on to find out that Ja Rule was the one
that was supposed to have the role and
something worked out where he wasn't
able to make it happen and I was the the
next person in line so when you hear
people say sloppy seconds sometimes it
could be a life-changing experience it's
I don't look at it as a bad term
especially sitting here in front of you
right now I'll take sloppy seconds
any day if it means I'm gonna be in
seven Fast and Furious movies
God damn right
trap cops and robbers it's 9-1-1 please
call the doctor the food was made
specifically for two Fast and Furious
John Singleton kind of gave me the whole
premise and told me this is what we need
and we went in the studio and made it
happen you know one of my finest
memories of that is shooting that video
and having the cast of Fast and Furious
be so much a part of it Paul Walker and
everybody and if you go look at it it's
just fun you could just instantly tell
it wasn't nobody forced anybody to have
any type of fun in there you know you
just we just had fun period And I bought
that car man I was in the movie and also
in that video it was like a Louis
Vuitton painted Dodge Ram truck or
something like that I probably was able
to drive it one time in Atlanta down the
road before I had a whole Fleet of the
whole city following me and then I was
like I got to get rid of this
car or I gotta paint it a different
color because there's no way that I want
this much attention that I thought I
wanted at first
man
stand up we were in the studio called
Doppler studio in Atlanta Georgia and
you know it's so dope to think about
this memory because it was literally
just me Kanye and an engineer he had his
ASR 10 with him you know he goes and
gets these samples and there are not
many sounds in this song it might be
like six sounds but he's so particular
when it comes to Sonic's that
to think about how that can become a hit
song because how things Pierce through
the speakers in a certain way and making
sure that every sound is perfect lets
you know how great of a producer and how
much he pays to every detail and I just
remember just being in the studio man
and it was just like stand up it just
came to me and again I went in the car
and then I started writing the first
verse and just out of this world that
was a record where I was like I know
this is a hit record I remember Irv
Gotti coming up to us because we were
all in the Def Jam building at the same
time everybody had their different
offices you know what I mean you have
Murder Inc you have Rockefeller you had
ours disturbing the peace that record
came out herb Gotti was like yo that's
what a first single supposed to
sound like man and you know we didn't
get that that much love from everybody
until they start embracing you over time
I was the only Southern artist in this
building everybody else is New York the
out DMX in there Jay-Z and Ja
Rule murder you know I mean Rockefeller
it was all New York so that one stand up
came out the was like we
embrace you welcome
to New York I pulled up
with a million trucks looking smelling
feeling like a million bucks what I
remember the most about the making of
that video Dave Myers man who I love to
work with so much he just is able to
take a vision and take it to the next
level you know that big ass shoe the
little person hanging from my necklace I
remember being on the video set and
somebody coming up to me he was a little
person and he said just so you know
is a derogatory term you
shouldn't say that it's little people
and I learned a lesson that day man and
it was a very valuable lesson and I have
so much respect for the little people
community so thank you for educating me
but you know that video is definitely
iconic in the sense of all the things
that were going on in there and just
augmenting reality that's what I love to
do welcome to Atlanta's Amazon boats
back to
Jermaine Dupree helped me get my start a
lot of people don't realize that uh
Madden 2000 I was the first rapper to be
on a video game rapping and he was the
one that gave me that opportunity so to
come full circle to get the record
welcome to Atlanta that was absolutely
amazing and now you know you fast
forward 20 years that is also a staple
not only for the City of Atlanta It's
brought so much tourism and money to the
city but for you to specify one city and
then the goats around the world and do
the record and people are just as
excited about it and you're not in that
City that you're speaking about speaks
volumes about how
much a record is loved when you're
saying welcome to Atlanta and you in New
York
take that never wind it back Lil Jon got
to beat the
beat them take that rewind it back or
sure got the voice to make your booty go
man Little John sent me the record you
know with Usher's lyrics on there
another record instantly as soon as I
heard I was in my house in Atlanta
instantly I was like this is out of
here it took me no time to write my
verse for it and I I was like this
is such a smash I gotta be on more than
just the verse so take that rewind it
back put that at the beginning and
at the end and they kept it in
the end so I was like I'm on this
I'm on this record
that first Grammy first BET Hip Hop
Award you know go back and look at that
clip I was excited as man because I
like again I'd been in all these
categories all these years wasn't
winning any awards that was the first
one
when I was 13 I had my first love there
was nobody that compared to my baby and
nobody came between us okay never come
above
like getting the call from Scooter Braun
and like deciding to do that it wasn't
even a call man I had a restaurant
called straights at the time he brought
Justin Bieber to us and he did this in
person so he came and was like yo man
this kid is your biggest fan he would
love you to be on this record just from
what it was perceived and looked like
because of how young he was and you know
him being from Canada and all this
different stuff I didn't look at or
listen to any of that it was strictly
based on me listening to the music and
believing in Justin Bieber as an artist
I didn't care age had nothing to do with
it race had nothing to do with it music
transcends all of those things so I said
yes I knew what it was and that record
was smash record and then all of a
sudden all of the rest of the hip-hop
Community embraced him the rest is
history
[Music]
you know there's certain elements that
you're like okay how does this fit in
the ludicrous world not only do how can
I get out of my comfort zone and
continue to do things that sometimes
people wouldn't expect me to do but it's
still trying to come with different
subject matter and working with an
artist that people may be you know
haven't seen me with I look for all of
these different things how much do I
believe in the record you know the tempo
of the record the time of the record all
of these different things so you know
um that's pretty much what I'm looking
for and when we did glamorous that was
another one that Polo brought to me and
the record was pretty much done when I
listened to it and all the elements to
me said this is definitely another smash
smash record Fergie was on fire at the
time anyway and it wasn't her first
single I don't believe I just remember
getting on there and just going with the
flow you know understand ending with the
subject was understanding the assignment
completing the assignment
hip-hop periods don't appreciate songs
that they feel like aren't that old
being sampled how do you feel about that
man I'm I'm okay with it you know what I
mean how can I not be okay with it you
know he he's I'm doing shows and people
there's a whole new generation that is
identifying with the record even if they
may not have heard my verse just because
Jack Harlow is doing it over and I feel
like he did it justice it'd be different
if it was trash it's not trash you know
what I mean Jack Harlow did it extreme
Justice and I like the record so I can I
understand where peers they're coming
from but if you don't if you don't
accept what's new
you'll become Your Own Worst Enemy you
don't have to necessarily like it but
you gotta embrace it now little Lisa is
only nine years old she's trying to
figure out why the world is so cold
while she's all alone and they never met
her family Runaway Love was a true test
and a very very strong risk in putting
out something completely opposite of
what people are you know used to
ludicrous coming out with and being
funny and being entertaining in the
sense of being light-hearted no this was
serious and it worked we have Mary J
Blige on it I remember Polo Le Don
produced the record I believe Carrie
Hilson helped write the hook of that and
she's in the background if I'm not
mistaken and I just want to say that you
talk about a record Being impactful This
Record spoke volumes towards actually
helping run away
victims come back home or find help in
the things that they were going through
in life so we talk about mental health
now this is one of those records that it
has such a powerful impact on
human beings in general because people
knew so many people that had either run
away or thought about running away and I
just feel like you know we hooked up
with the 1-800 hotline and we partnered
with them and so it was just one of
those records that had a hell of an
impact and then Kiki Palmer you know one
of her first music videos if not her
first music video she was in this video
uh Runaway Love and the rest is history
you can see her Evolution over the
decades from that and I couldn't be more
proud we just saw her the other day at
the Janet Jackson concert and I was
expressing to her you know how proud I
was of her till this day I still get
people coming up to me saying thank you
for putting out that record you have no
idea how it impacted their life or how
it got a loved one back to them because
of it or help them call someone just to
get help and get things off their chest
and to prevent someone from running away
release therapy was extremely important
and I can tell you how important it was
to win that best rap album category
because
I'd say the seven years previous to that
I was in the category I was nominated
for best rap album but Eminem would
pretty much take it every single time
and so you know I just kept I didn't
give up I said I'm gonna take this damn
rap album on one time and I would be in
this category with everybody else Jay-Z
DMX Eminem that was pretty much it and I
took it home that year man and it meant
the world to me because that's what I
set out to do so they're not taking it
from me this year no no no I'm saying my
chick bad my chick Hood my chick do
stuff that your chick when she could my
chick back very young Nicki Minaj on
that how familiar had you been with like
her mixtapes and her work up until I
have been familiar with it she was
living in Atlanta at the time she was
being managed by Deborah Anthony and she
was around Gucci a lot at the same time
and I uh I noticed a lot of similarities
in how she likes to have fun in her
music and how it's theatrical and I
think that it was the perfect matchup
and marriage to throw her on that record
and the timing was perfect as well
because her rise to super stardom was
just beginning and I just love that she
was in that video and even more to do a
remix video with all women this is
before women have become dominant in
hip-hop currently right now I set out
during this battle of the sexes album to
be like we need more women voices in
hip-hop and that's exactly what I did so
humbly speaking if you look at the years
before what I was trying to do and now
it's actually happening you see that I
was just ahead of the game
[Music]
I didn't even know that was my most
watched video on YouTube but it's great
to know that because man when you look
at the discography of records that I
have man sometimes it blows me away and
I'm on stage and I'm like damn we gotta
that is another one I forgot about to
know that the crowd is forgetting about
how many records I got it you'd be
surprised sometimes I forget how
many hit records I got
[Music]
Ludacris
lockdown DJ Khaled handed me the layup
of life with that damn record and
whoever else is on it so Rick Ross Snoop
I will be able to perform this record
among some of my other records till the
day I expire on this Earth
because it is along with Move one
of those records that is always going to
get the best reaction from any crowd any
race any age any generation so that's
how I feel about all I do is win it's
out of here the fact that I went
first on that record is even better for
the artist named Ludacris it's out of
here we out every sporting event
every event where anyone can actually
win anything that is the theme song for
Life period man where do I see myself in
hip-hop history I see myself ingrained
in hip-hop history not only through my
music but through my personality man and
uh you know standing out and being in
you know influential and being unique
you know as unique as my sideburns are
right now man loving and doing things
that other people follow but just
knowing that I was the one that
originated it I think that's what means
the most to me having a chapter in the
book of hip-hop means the world to me
and having fans argue about me being one
of the best rappers of all time that
means more to me than you could possibly
imagine most of the people they put in
that category only do music so for me to
be multi-faceted and still be in the
category of best that's what means the
world to me